cioè sì sì sì sì sì sì certo bravo
questo gioco lotito non me ne frega un
cazzo farmi giocare
ero così da bambino quando giocava sta
roba già giusto per ricordarsi vecchi
tempi
tutti ragazzi e permettetemi sono video
sono fa vigenti oggi siamo su dragon
ball csen verso milano sale da rappo
proprio con questa pronuncia madonna con
un ragazzo a parte sta intro bellissima
a parte tutto sono un fan assurdo di
dragon ball da quando ero piccolo e c'è
quando è uscito sto gioco io ho dato di
matto
giuro che se devo fare qua a nuovi e
figo posso scegliere se essere majin
sayan terrestre nam e ciano e candy
friser è un figo perché a trovare la
scelta più difficile della mia vita va
bene e io andrei di tra questi dai 6
anni è la più claro so che la più
classica frega casse goku dietro sta
scendendo una lacrima giuro e siccome ci
si personalizza il personaggio ed è una
cosa troppo [ __ ] vedevo di farlo bello
gnocco ragazzi alla prima cosa alto un
cazzo perfetto tipo di corporatura
magrissimo capelli più scrausi droga sì
faccio la persona più brutta che
potreste mai vedere nella vita direi
ecco questa e la serve voglio fare la
corsa della vita fermi nati ok c'è la
dimmi che c'è il colore della pelle
perfetto ragazzi è un [ __ ] ananas è
bellissimo ma vabbè dai bee stupendo cev
io lo amo assume parte superiore mio dio
cioè ragazzi mi sento l'uomo barbie e
sotto questa incredibile vestaglia sexy
si nasconde un uomo bruto l'ananas
brutto è una lo zio ragazzi che cazzo
stoffa c'è avete vicente quegli occhi
profondi che ti entrano nell'anima c'è
proprio tipo
ecco questi senza l'audio di e voldemort
la barbetta che brutta persona cosa per
te ragazzi orribile mi dispiace per
quest'uomo non volevo farlo così brutto
ma
e capitato male come cioè una roba tipo
di tematiche renderman praticamente
bellissima vabbè ho creato slider mensud
dragon ball z c'è la pace la voce pure
ma veramente sei serio e grosso come la
mia casa ecc a questa voce
ok ma che lo stanno mettendo nel
didietro cose a posto per quanto
riguarda il papa troller il nome
standard e pat roller perché spiegano
avrà un p patrol cioè qualsiasi nome
credo che sia meglio di patron ma va
bene tipo ho la testa pelata ma bella ah
cazzo non ci sta ma bella e vabbè dai lo
sapete voi ho la testa pelata
questo è il mio nome bellissimo sono
pronto per salvare mobili così guarda
come carico cazzo che bello è morto
succede nel servito un cazzo tutto
questo mister satana e cos'è sarò o mio
dio o la testa pelata
è un esultanza del tipo se già la testa
pelata fai il morto come oh mio dio è
morto in mezzo alle scale sto povero
cristo
gretaia meno mio dio e vabbè è la
madonna che cosa ragazzi io metterei
della tectonic
fusione o mio dio no no fermi grosso
junior non sono io che son nano io
combatto contro i giganti non pensavo di
essere così i nano cazzo junior
preparati che dobbiamo fare una cosa
[ __ ] ci sei
al mio tre 123 ai dei tempi di reazione
che fanno invidia mia nonna junior da mi
interessa ragazzi mi faccia combattere
che mi sembra cerca di sconfiggere mi
serie c riceverai una ricompensa
ho paura a vederti così con tipo stupro
però che sconfigge junior ma vederci
prova ragazzi non ho idea di come cazzo
si combatta ma va bene fotte sega
allenamento junior sì sì sì piccolo poi
non è capito quello che hanno piccole
bruttissimo sommano è alto due metri e
mezzo porca [ __ ]
io non so come si combatte recava un po
di training al grazie a volte ti faccio
assaggiare lasagne di mia nonna che ti
sbattono a terra ugual come faccio è
perché senti in anno di merda fai
qualcosa come paul e meteorite vai e
cosa fa ma fai qualcosa
madonna non glielo da te vai così poi
così fa vedere che ci si è un cazzo ci
sono gli fai culo dai dai call super
salto frontale forza
madonna cosa succede e aperto al menu
che tutto parte della mia mossa è letale
questa raffica di energia potenza ma
quanto ti sto facendo il culo zio
mamma mia che umiliazione per azione
allora io ho giocato quando da piccolo
giocava avuto peta inca c2
era il mio preferito ma porca vacca non
avevo vita che lo facessero così bene
anche 69 e non so se si vede perché mi
ha fatto leggermente il culo doni lo
junior di merda ti ammazzo la famiglia
l'importante è partecipare ragazzi e
vabbè che bello quando ti prendi di
steroidi ezio certo così ora basta
sparisci dalla mia vista ma lo scasso di
botte perché ragazzi è che possiamo
passare i combattimenti quelli fatti che
contro maroni non questo perché sennò
junior mi fa il culo ma che ha preso di
steroidi mettere sul personaggio che
caso mio dio che ricordi per l'isla tu
mi stai sicuro è un due contro due
fatemi fare gol anche goku super sayan
god che è figo ave ragazzi come prima
direi andare sul classico quindi gioco a
manetta e poi prendiamo tipo locazione
sua vegetale non se riesco a trovare un
e getta figo o mio dio ai vestiti
strappati con l'aureola che stile cosa
cazzo è questa roba fantasticava dei
ragazzi prendo lui perché mi sa troppo
di cazzuto dai [ __ ] ormai che mi sta
sul culo abbastanza da poter sempre da
calci mi sento carica tipo madonna
quanto sono caduti tutti quanti anzi mi
fa impressione giuro sono già partiti
non voglio spaventarti vegeta ma devi
fare tutto tu perché io faccio pagare ho
fallito non da energetiche in modo
troppo strano vabbè mica che porta mai
così ci facciamo ce la facciamo da
junior di mel tu sei mio perché aveva
tutto prima stronzo camion era veloce
se il premio donna che ballo è morto dai
ragazzi li ho fatto e sto facendo un
culo da madonna
questa volta non arrivi e bastard magari
perché non sono un anno dai cazzo
stavolta ti faccio il culo ma anche nota
[ __ ] ragazzi non scappa come si
scappa veloce perché vi sia qualcosa
delle mosse
porca [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] cosa è
successo se stoppata la registrazione
perfetto jonio sei una merda mi ha fatto
stoppare anche il gioco ragazzino dello
devo rifare perché una questione di vita
o di morte ne frega un cazzo cioè non
esiste
eccoti qua vieni vieni vieni qua lurido
hafez sente come faccia è completamente
diverso da com'era l'altro dragon il
canape va beh
mettiamoci anche gesù se avete voglia a
lui lo strano sotto visto dato giorno
che guardavi mia moglie bastardo niente
non ci penso mi deve fare il culo
sto stronzo di merda te la prendi punta
nel culo è niente l'ho mancato di
prodotto sentite c'è una roba tipo super
che a me a me ha ritirato a con
giravolta o miopia me ne frega niente
finché non lo batte
vai così tra il cazzo l'ho preso l'ho
preso l'ho preso per ci godo come la
vita cosa vuol dire sta frase bye bye
bye bye bye verrà mai veloci veloci
[ __ ] stronzo tu sei sempre stato
sicuro perché sei verde sono razzista
nei confronti dei verdi un ragazzo sta
mettendo [ __ ] ma il camion era
veloce di nuovo grock bye bye
se l'ho preso cazzo dai che ce la faccio
picchia non ci sto credendo fallo di
nuovo file nuovo fallo di nuovo caso non
c'è ormai mi ha preso in pieno cazzo va
beh son dettagli mai mai mai e prima che
tv melo ger no ma perché non ci fosse
non mi incazzo fink angelo che mi
incazzo
se ho vinto io
[Musica]
quanta vita ciao ragazzi ho vinto io non
so come c'è trans che però ci sta
battendo tutti e due potrebbe essere un
problema questo non so come faremo ma
città come ho fatto a tornare in pista
già chi fosse un'area già è vero perché
va a quante uccisioni fi perfetto la
sera esisto 13 secondi io vi abbiamo
vinto però c'è scampo a cazzo dove
esiste da dieci secondi sono muoio mai
glocus che ci puoi fare più veloce di
valentino vai così sul cap nome di
questo tutta nel culo questo io mi hanno
stai vedendo cazzo abbiamo vinto siamo
fatta non ci posso credere anno farei a
cazzo è vero che l'abbiamo fatto uno a
uno per che vegeta e morto la merda di
vegeta e cosa timori ho resistito io non
sono nè resistito to coast affaccia
cazzuta che c'hai sei morto ragazzine
che posso concludere qui vi do spero che
vi sia piaciuto perché è un gioco un
pochettino diverso da quelli che faccio
di solito ma ho voluto farlo perché c'è
dragon ball è stata mia la mia infanzia
esattamente la mia infanzia quindi
volevo assolutamente farlo perché mi
diverto troppo a giocare a sta roba
spero vi sia piaciuto ragazzi di sapere
se volete anche altri episodi se no
vabbè faccio solo questo come sento
servito è piaciuta sotto punto mi piace
anche a precari facebook e come nani
video trovate né descrizione pero non mi
piace che mettete un capello in più da
super sayan è un pelo di barba in meno
che ne ha bisogno che vedete se volessi
discreti nocivi diavolo prossimo video
belle ragazze